today I'm going to talk about how to
paralyze nd soul I'm going to give you a
description of different methods that
can be used I'm going to give you an
outline of the method that I've chosen
and then I'll give you some examples of
some applications so this came out of
some discussions we were having for the
new compiler where we're looking for
ways to paralyze code applications in
Mathematica and application areas so one
candidate is nd soul it's what it's
widely used it has many application
areas it has a fairly modern design it
solves computationally intensive
problems it's got a rich set of accurate
solvers that have a well optimized and
it uses this vectorized framework for
solving differential equations which is
a good candidate for paralyzation so
there are several approaches to
parallelization so the first one is to
actually paralyze the arithmetic that's
inside the method so we do things like
multi-threading the vector arithmetic
the function evaluation and
multi-threading the linear algebra using
some special-purpose libraries the
advantage is that it improves all
methods you know any any method that
uses a vector framework will get an
advantage from multi-threaded vector
arithmetic the disadvantage is that the
thresholds have reason to be high so you
need a system with like a thousand or
10,000 equations before it can be
multi-threaded so another way to
paralyze is to paralyze across the
method so the method itself inside will
farm off to different different threads
or different processes so there's a
large literature on parallel integration
methods the drawback is that we often
need special methods to work better in
parallel like a standard runge-kutta
method or something like that it's not
immediately paralyzed abour because in
its internals each stage is coupled
strongly with this
stage before and it needs to work in a
serial fashion so we didn't have to
implement a new set of methods that
would be paralyzed Abul and these would
only work for specific specific types of
problems okay so a lot of work for a
little game so another approach is to
actually discretize discretize the
actual problem that we're interested in
now there are many many methods
available some work in the spatial
domain and some work in the temporal
domain so the choice that I've made as a
first approach here which seems to fit
well into into nd solve is a parallel in
time discretization that's the method
that we're going to consider so solving
nd solve each nd solve method also an
initial value problem it's like a
mathematical nest function it's
inherently serial so each application of
the function on the one before has to be
done to get the next value you have to
apply it over and over again to the same
value before so the idea is here instead
of solving for endpoints we're going to
subdivide n into little pieces we're
going to compute a different function G
instead of F okay over some subdivided
grid and we're going to iteratively
correct these points in order to
converge to F so the method that I've
implemented called the parallel power
real method it's one of the most widely
studied parallel in time methods for
solving differential equations in
parallel it's introduced it's quite
recent it's introduced in 2001 there's
been a huge amount of study on this
method method the properties of the
method when it gives good results when
it doesn't give good results the
numerical stability of the method it's a
very general purpose method which is
good because then we get we can get a
wide set of problems that we can apply
it to since the method was invented it's
been discovered to be at what's called a
two-level nonlinear multigrid algorithm
multigrid reduction in
time and multilevel algorithms are
extremely efficient it's designed in its
origins that exascale computations
that's really really big computations
fortune 500 companies people solving
extremely large problems okay so that's
the motivation for that method now it
turns out that this it's extremely well
into the existing and Diezel framework
it works well with one-step methods of
which nd solve has a wide variety it
uses existing tools for concurrency so
that's math link Mathematica and sub
kernels and parallel computing and it
uses very few parallel directors
parallel evaluate parallel table paper
distribute definitions so here's an
outline of the method how it works we
want to solve this initial value problem
over a time interval so we'll subdivide
this time interval into little pieces
where the number of subdivisions is the
number of processors or the number of
parallel computations that we're going
to be doing ok so we have a time
interval say 0 to 10 and almost we'll
chop it up into smaller time slices by
chopping up into these uniform slices
that's a uniform distribution of work in
parallel ok now the parallel method
works were using two numerical
integration methods not one it uses a
low order cheap method that's this Jie
method here and it uses the original
method that we're going to compare
against the fine
the so-called fine method but the point
is the cheap method that's done on to a
lower accuracy is very efficient that's
the one that's done in serial so we're
placing an expensive computation in
serial with a cheap computation in
serial and then we're going to do the
expensive computation with the original
method that we're interested but we're
going to do in parallel ok so we do a
big serial step we do a parallel step
and then we go and iteratively correct
until we get some sort of convergence
so here's a mathematical outline of this
thing this is what this standard
integration would be like with the
standard integration method over over
the grid that's been discretized so the
parallel per a real iteration is is this
it starts off with a coarse solution
using a lower order integrator instead
of a higher order integrator then it
goes and uses the high order integrator
on the solution that was found here but
it does this bit in parallel then it
goes and forms a correction and it goes
again and does another serial
computation but using the improved
solution that was found correcting from
the from the parallel computation okay
and then you just go and iterate this
over and over and over again until
convergence and hopefully if the number
of iterations that you're doing small
compared to the number of parallel
processes that you have it converges
very quickly and you get a good speed up
so I did a little movie to show you but
it's not comparable to stop sailing
video that he just showed off skip that
and and move on to something a little
bit move on to something a little bit if
we have time at the end I could show you
a little movie so a bit about the design
of this method inside nd salt so there
are several ways the traditional way to
do it is to write it as like a driver
method so this thing discretize is to
mash in it you have to write some
methods and very often it's done with a
simple fixed step size explicit method
or something which is not even good for
a problem something like that so what we
really wanted to incorporate it into a
nice way inside nd solve so a driver
method will be something like parametric
ND salt does at the moment it does some
kind of processing on top for the
different parameters that it needs to
solve and then it goes and calls nd
solve for each value of that parameter
and that's the kind of design that's
done conventionally so this has got
several limitations if you have a really
long time integration like up to a time
a thousand or ten thousand or something
you don't the convergence is going to be
very slow even if you've got like
hundred or a thousand processes
something like that
so we're going to flip things around
we're going to make the parallel pyro
rule method go inside induce all from it
so it's a time stepping method and it's
not going to work on the whole
integration interval it's not going to
work some from say T goes from zero to a
thousand it's only going to work on a
little piece at a time
say zero to ten and then ten to twenty
and twenty to thirty thirty to forty etc
etc etc and then inside each sub
computation it will still be doing stuff
in parallel whether but on a smaller
integration region and the important
point is here when having event-driven
computations you don't know where some
event is going to happen so often you
write in indie solve like T goes from
zero to infinity now with a parallel
method you couldn't discretize an
infinite time no matter how many
processes you have but if you break this
down into time units small time unit
blocks you just go ten at a time then
eventually you'll get to some event
doesn't matter how long it takes so
that's the advantage of having it sort
of flipped on its head and having the
parallel real method inside in these off
and this is a little bit similar in
spirit to some of the actual methods in
in diesel so the main thing that had to
be done to make this method work
efficiently is to change the main data
structure in Indi solve so in these
whole cows what's called a state data
object when nd soul starts up it
converts this problem it does an
analysis of this problem and it sets up
all sorts of things it might need like
index reduction initial conditions all
sorts of things that are going to be
needed and it makes this big data object
then it's going to use that data object
to carry it along from step to step and
then update the information inside that
now this data object is quite big and
quite heavyweight in the para real
method we're going to need several of
these data objects we don't need the
main one for the para real method we're
going to need another one for the serial
method we're going to need another one
on each sub kernel for each of the
parallel integrations so we're going to
make copies of this thing we need
lightweight copies of this thing
so I've changed this data structure it's
much similar in spirit now to
Association it's what's called a roar
expression it's a very little
lightweight wrapper around a big C data
structure and it's only converted to
this big bulky form that we saw here
when it's sent over math link and that
allows me to continuously update and
reset this this data structure without
having to worry about this big bulky
representation gives me kind of a a much
more lightweight way of way of working
with with this data structure now the
parallel primitives they're really only
two parallel primitives that this method
uses it has to launch and close sub
kernels for the method to work it has to
send that main nd solve object to each
parallel kernel that fee for the method
to work and then at the end it has to
clean up after itself the actual main
computation is just a simple loop using
parallel table it calls the the nd solve
parallel stepping method on some Grid
interval with initial conditions and
corrections here so it's a very simple
this is designed to work with vector
data and it's a very simple call to
parallel table the important thing is to
keep that thing very simple because
that's going to be called every single
time you do a parallel computation
calling the evaluator is quite expensive
compared to the actual time that we're
going to spend doing the integration so
I've set up the data to be in order to
make this as simple as possible just a
quick thing about Andy solve another
thing that was needed and indeed always
a finalized a finalized method so we
have a method initialization that sets
up things like method coefficients
workspaces data structures that the
method actually is going to need here
we're going to need a finalized method
because we're going to go need to clean
up afterwards we're gonna need to close
kernels that have been launched or if
the kernels are persistent we're going
to go need to clean out data there's
left in each of those sub kernels okay
so we're going to need a finalized a
finalized step inside in yourself okay
so this is the basic method how it works
in D solve it does its equation
processing it gets to the power real
method the parallel method goes in it
initializes data sets up sub kernels it
initializes the sub methods and it sets
up data structures it's going to need
and then it gets to the actual iteration
method it goes and calls a low order
method in serial and then it goes and
calls higher order methods in parallel
and then it goes again
after another iteration working out a
corrective step here and does another
serial computation and so on and so on
so until you get convergence and then it
gets to the end of this particular sub
grid or computation if that's the end of
the time integration interval then we're
done otherwise it will go back and do
the next chunk of computation okay so
this part goes back to itself and then
eventually we get to the finalized part
where we go and do the cleanup and then
we process the solutions to the
interpolating functions in nd solve okay
so the speed-up of the power of real
method it depends on the cost of solving
in serial the cost of solving in
parallel the number of iterations that
are needed for convergence and also the
number of parallel but processes that
are running there's also some kind of
latency and data copying and that kind
of thing so here's a very simple example
this is just a kind of trivial equation
here that we're solving over a specific
time it's just the time that nd solve
takes to solve this using an explicit
ruler Kutta method okay now this is the
power of real method the syntax for the
power real method it takes a serial
method and it takes a parallel method
now in this case they're both the same
the order of this method is going to be
lower than this method this is going to
be a higher order method a lower or the
method because in serial we're solving
using lower tolerance
we're telling it so maybe soul only to
10 to the minus 3 or 10 to the minus 4
and so the method automatically will
choose a lower order scheme here
compared to the high water scheme then
you see there's a quite expensive
competitive 0.02 that we had before but
the point is a lot of that overhead is
not actually the method itself it's
actually launching and closing the
parallel kernels so if we actually
launch the kernels beforehand and then
go and call the nd solved method and
then close the kernels afterwards then
it becomes much more competitive it's
less than a factor of 10 for this this
is a trivial problem that's not paralyse
double at all so this is kind of a worse
case for this method okay now I'm really
trying to get this overhead to be as
small as possible so that you can you
can try it and so within a factor of 10
is okay I'll be happy with a factor of 5
or something like that one on trivial
problems as a worst case scenario okay
so that's something I spent a long time
developing this method purely in serial
just to bring the overhead down as much
as possible now if you actually look at
this the the computation here this is
the solution of the explicit runge-kutta
method and these are the two solutions
one launching the kernels locally and
and launching the kernels globally of
course these are identical
it's nothing matter if I Lawson globally
or locally but but just willing just
wanted to check that that that was the
case now the other thing that you can do
here is I can call this parallel have a
real method but I can call it now with
high precision ok this is really quite
new the implementation the whole
parallel framework I mean is like less
than a week old that the parallel
parameters are working this I got
working on Monday on the plane on the
way out so you know don't expect don't
expect huge things for the first
iteration of this method but it does
work and it gives me a reference
solution that I can compare to these two
these two here and this is the solution
converted back to machine precision and
if you compare these digits you'll see
that there's about an extra digit of
accuracy in the peril of real method but
they're both within the order of the
error estimation the accuracy goal and
the precision goal has been
decide that's the important thing here
and the important thing is that this
method also works for a high precision
reference solution okay so let me get to
a PDE example now the nice thing okay I
just need two minutes the nice thing
about the nice thing about having this
method inside Indy solve is it can
leverage off all the things that nd
solved us so when in this you do solve
processes PDE s one of the methods that
uses a method of lines it will do a
discretization and then it becomes
purely an OD problem okay so I can leave
Ridge off that I can use the the
processing that the nd solve does when
it sets up this grid to solve this PDE
so here's my Bruce later PDE and here's
just to show you that it does actually
work for solving PDEs so here i've
chosen a method that the switch is
adaptively when the when the problem
becomes stiff and i've chosen that both
for my cereal and my parallel method now
of course this is going to be a lower
order method because the tolerances are
smaller and there's going to be a higher
order method and it does actually work
you can see this I've actually managed
to solve this PDE but what about the run
time so I want shown at least one
example where I got kind of some speed
up with this method at least even if
it's just in its in its infancy so
here's one for this for this some
related problem now it needs a little
bit of if I just call nd solve with a
stiffness switching method this is a 16
core machine okay then it takes about
almost half a second to solve this PD
problem if I call power real with with
the same method for the serial and
parallel computation it takes a little
bit longer so it's no real speed-up 16
cause this method is really designed for
many many cause 200,000 something ok so
if I can get it to be competitive you
know for a small number of cause then
then I'm doing a reasonable job but the
really important thing is here so the
parallel method is using a stiff solver
because this this system
that is solving become stiff it has to
do linear algebra stuff like that the
serial method is done to a lower
tolerance and that's not necessarily a
stiff problem okay so I can use what's
called a stabilized runge-kutta method
in NDS hole and that's an explicit
method it's an explicit method but it
has a wider stability domain so there's
no linear algebra there's no additional
overhead of a stiff solver and so the
serial computations in this parallel
will in this parallel method are done
using a very cheap very efficient work
method and what was necessarily to do
before in a serial way using an
expensive stiff solver has now been
pushed down to the parallel solver okay
so I'm using the stiff solver in
parallel but I'm using a much cheaper
much lower order much more efficient
thing to do the computation in serial
and then I'm going in correcting and I'm
already able even on a machine that is
not really designed for AI I'm already
able to get something that is faster so
the implications for the new compiler
and that's one of the reasons why we
started this project in the first place
is what do we focus on how do we kind of
develop functionality of the compiler
and how does that feed back into
Mathematica so the real thing to take
away there is that we should really be
focusing on on lower order lower
accuracy methods and paralyzing those or
making those more efficient because
that's the thing in the serial step here
in this parallel method those are really
the methods that are going to give us
the biggest benefit of course we should
continue to paralyze very arithmetic but
we should choose like look in this over
traditionally has been focusing on
solving equations very accurately and it
has a good set of higher-order
reasonably expensive methods to do that
but now if we can push to having a new
set of solvers that are very cheap for
simpler lower order solutions that will
benefit this method
so there are some optimizations that I
still have to do here I can save one
over P 1 over the number of processes
work because after the first iteration I
don't need the first sub kernel that
could give me some kind of redundancy or
fault recovery I have a sub kernel extra
sub kernel sitting there not doing
anything after the first iteration
that's an optimization that I haven't
done yet other things that the method
needs maybe a better starting step
estimate to make the method restarting
more efficient need to go and reduce the
overhead inside nd so when these always
set up so that does a lot of work and
then does a big long integration but
it's not so good when I have to do lots
of small kind of restarted integrations
which is the kind of things that this
that this method requires and they also
need to be a bit more careful when I
setup my grid for parallel computation
to take account of discontinuity points
and points coming in from events that I
haven't quite haven't quite implemented
that yet but the thing to take away here
is even in its form at the moment it's
still quite state-of-the-art because you
just choose the methods built-in to nd
solve you just select your method for
serial you select your method for for
parallel and it will go and do that in
most of the implementation is in the
literature you really have to go and
implement your own OD solvers for the
soup for the for the serial and parallel
methods you have to choose the step
sizes you have to do all sorts of things
but nd solve does automatically for you
just by calling it within this framework
because of the richness of nd solving we
have non stiff and stiff solvers things
that work adaptively now the method
works best for a large number of cores
but because we like to flip things
around and put it as a OD like a solver
method inside in d solve we can solve
the problem iteratively for smaller
blocks of time which is good for event
Ament based computation now I haven't
haven't implemented universally for all
nd sold methods
delay differential equations
differential algebraic equations there
are a lot of extensions of this method
that can come over time this is kind of
a proof of concept to see that the
method actually works and can give us
something useful and in a good direction
forum for the future okay so I'm
finished so if anyone has any questions
then
[Applause]